last time we broke out of a chicken farm
well this
time we're breaking
in it's an impossible
mission they're going to turn everyone
into nuggets find those
chickens hang on
Fowler oh there go the
gons we can do
this what were some of the challenges
and what did you talk about when you
started planning what the sequel would
would cover would cover trying to come
up with an idea that felt like a worthy
followup uh because the first film was
um so nicely received and then each year
it it uh kind of kept growing
in popularity part of it was that artman
had a a deal at DreamWorks and had gone
on to uh do flushed away and then
Jeffrey kenberg was always very keen to
do Wallace and grommet film and you know
it takes a long time to make these
movies and so you know each one taking
three four years rolling into the next
one uh that took a little while uh but
mostly we were trying to figure out what
the what the best idea was and so when
when I got the call from armman saying
we're we're talking I mean this might
have been
2013 uh we're thinking about doing
another a sequel finally uh we me and
Nick and Pete this was before Paul was
involved um instantly landed on the same
premise which was this time they're
breaking in felt like the most logical
uh Next Step you definitely kept the
feel of the first one but there was a
fire um famous fire would you tell us
how that impacted yeah it's funny
anybody who's ever worked at ardman is
used to it's it was like one of the
natur you know national disasters in the
UK was the fire that happened at adman
but actually it happened in a storage
facility um and it was difficult because
the key thing with making these films is
actually the molds for the characters so
the characters themselves over time I'm
afraid degrade and will fall apart so
you'd have to remake them but we lost
all the molds in that fire so one of the
challenges here was the first thing we
had to do was redesign all of the
puppets from scratch so even we know we
knew what they look like they're
actually completely original would you
tell us a little bit about some of the
sets like how how large was uh uh the um
the comp pound for example well as kri
said the you know the the facility where
things are made is a massive Warehouse
on the outskirts of Bristol and what we
do would is divide the floor up into
different units so some of the units
would be really small um you know
literally a character on a table this
kind of size here and then you go right
up to the layer which would be enormous
and one of the challenges always is
about scale is that you can't get too
big
because the roof is a limitation in the
building so often you would do set
extensions you know so either digitally
or you'd film extra elements elsewhere
and then stick them together in post but
the you know the sets can be massive and
it's quite a physical job then for the
animators isn't it Carri they they have
to climb over the the sets to try and
animate the characters and it is you
know takes a long time the set for the
island and all those Huts was probably
from the edge of this step to you know
maybe 10 rows back and from aisle to
aisle that one particular set is massive
if you're a fan of making Legos or like
I mean that's what it is on the most
amaz like a big toy shop it is it's on
just the most amazing scale and um my
wife and I actually toured the floor one
day and you go in and it's really
jawdropping to look at these miniature
sets and the level of detail and then
there's poles everywhere holding the you
know the the uh the characters in place
every you know one of the things if
you're a fan of artman one of the things
that you love is you go through the film
and you're always going to see thumb
prints and fingerprints on characters's
necks and I just love the lowte I love
the fact that you feel the human touch
literally on these films in fact CG's
gotten so good today that they could go
in and fake putting those in if they
want but they they don't do that
actually to what extent did you use
newer techniques or stay with the
original well they used them all the
time you I think it's it because it's
such an
old film making technique stop motion it
goes way back to the beginning of film
making you're still trying to keep you
know that process alive but then all of
the extra things are about either
speeding things up so you can make the
process slightly faster or you can make
things bigger you know and that that's
the advantage so you're always looking
at ways to do that to improve the
ability to kind of you know make the
film slightly cheaper to make or make
them larger with the money you've got um
so there are set extensions which can be
digital they can be physically built
bits of set that then we we we stick in
with green screen um you know everything
is evolving so even the puppet
technology is impressive you know when
you really understand what sits
underneath the puppets and how the model
makers make them it's you know it's
extraordinary so it's a it's a very low
tech form of film making with lots of
high technology in IT Crowd scenes get a
lot easier with CG the technology is so
much better I can't tell the difference
between which chickens or clay
especially in the big crowd scene so in
the first film and and we have a The
Shot opens this film from the first film
where all the chickens are lined up
there were literally that many chickens
uh and the one of the problems in the
first film is we had to do everything on
two different scales we had an an a
scale and a b scale so the chickens are
not much bigger than this um and then
the Mrs Tweety model would be you know
this tall um but if we so you can't put
those two in the same shot together um
but if we had to keep it to scale then
Mrs Tweety would be human size and you
can't make a model that big so when
they're in the same shot you had to you
know we would make boots and things like
that to be in the shot um and now with
computers we don't have to they didn't
have to build on two different scales no
not as much you don't use as much as you
would have originally and yeah so it
it's great it it still allows you to do
what you know what's important in the
process and things like cleanup is the
other thing that you don't think about
is when you have a character that's the
size that car's talking about and you
put it on a screen like this a tiny
Speck of dust looks enormous it looks
like a rock on the face of the character
so originally you'd spend hours cleaning
the characters and they still try to do
that but we have the advantage now we
can send it off to to to a CG you know
VFX and to do a quick cleanup but you
you do really still feel that you know
the hand of the artist yeah exactly very
much and that's the that's the cas and
that that has stayed consistent but I
don't think what people realize in
animation is that the animators are the
other half of the acting they get the
voice first you know the actors are
coming in and doing it vocal only and
then with the help of Sam trying to
figure out how those things get
physicalized is them bringing their own
acting ability to these characters and
I'd love it the artman movies always
have you know these wonderful references
and aage to other films and gags and uh
this was no exception yes um what are
some of your favorites in this film my
absolute favorite gag and I wish I had
written it but my favorite gag in the
movie is the retinal
scan um and going inside and it's just a
lowtech book of eyeballs that you're
looking at that was a storyboard I know
it was a storyboard artist and that's
the other great thing about animated
movies is that story storyboard artists
unlike in you know in live action
they're
primarily plotting camera moves and and
particularly on an effects heavy movie
but storyboard artists in animation are
an addendum to the writing team you know
they're bringing gags they're bringing
um you know great humor and detail
especially through physical comedy so
all of that I mean uh when John and I
were writing the first draft we wrote
some gags and you can imagine looking at
movies like Oceans 11 and Mission
Impossible and you know that um it's
it's just fun to see chickens doing
these things for some
reason especially the chickens that look
like this with these massive teeth but
um all the use of of um you know
Ginger's rubber sucker gun and throwing
in the ruler that splits open and holds
open the you know the Ingenuity that you
would see in ad Mission Impossible and
bringing that down to household props
and and discarded things that you would
find in a junkyard and them repurposing
those I just think is such the charm of
these movies um because you're taking
advantage of scale um and the uniqueness
of the of the world that you're in I
mean it's you got to take advantage of
the fact that you're
animating how involved were um Nick Park
and uh Peter Lord in this yeah uh well
very early on um in the early
development U Nick was off um making his
wall ear man was well he was finishing
early man he was exhausted and then he's
on to another Wallace and grommet movie
um Pete was very involved uh every step
of the way uh but you know the one thing
when Sam Fel came on who's a very
experienced uh director in his own right
and out of respect for him you know we
had to sort of you know here's I I wrote
the film created these characters Nick
and Pete um created them uh directed the
first film but it was our job to sort of
step back and play a supporting role so
that Sam could sort of make this movie
his own which he did a a beautiful job
of but with with the guidance of of Pete
as one of the owners of ardman and
overseeing everything uh and just sort
of kind of making sure that that we're
all staying in the same Chicken Run
universe that we knew and had created um
so um Pete more so than Nick only
because Nick was uh off trying to crack
his own Wallace and gromet story but
every screening every draft um uh and
them always weighing in because they're
just a wealth of great ideas yeah it's
it's a very collaborative process isn't
it I think yeah well all of you the
whole team did created a wonderful and
fun film and uh it will be uh streaming
worldwide uh December 15th on Netflix um
thank you so much for joing us
congratulations thanks for sticking
around yeah